she got really comfortable at one part
and then as she was getting comfortable
I was too this is what I was gonna say
about Billy eilish's star power so she's
sitting in the chair you're in now Matt
and she as you both saw almost
immediately she got so comfortable she
started to and no other guest has done
this she started to slide down the chair
and she just kept sliding down the chair
until I was basically just looking at
Billy eilish's head yeah resting on the
chair her body completely disappeared
and Phineas got very comfortable and
then at one point out of the corner of
my eye look over and I see Sona and you
were mirroring Billy eilish you were way
down as if you were on a
transcontinental flight In First Class
yeah you reclined all the way you
ordered some warm cashews and a Pinot
Noir and yeah you put out an eye mask
you were so chill and I was sitting on a
milk bucket in the shadows
ha ha ha ha ha